[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are talking about our recent
trips to North kakalaki North Carolina
unexpected trip for you uh planned trip
for me
um basically how this ended up working
is you originally made plans to go to
Mexico Cabo San Lucas and uh this was an
exciting thing for you uh me and Chris
you decided to go with another couple
other than me and my wife which uh we
did not you didn't consult with me uh
but we were on your toes we've worked
through it and when you made that
decision to be gone over a long weekend
uh Jesse was like Hey the weekend that
Lincoln Christian are gone we should go
back to North Carolina because she's got
cabin business is what we call it and
that's not a euphemism for anything
that's just we you know we have a place
that we are fixing up in North Carolina
and we needed to meet the contractor Etc
yeah so we planned a trip that would
coincide with us with the exact days
that you were gone
and then little did I know things
happened that family members and and
close family friends and on Christy's
side
we're going to be dropping like flies
okay yep
uh yeah I I went to two funerals in one
day and I want to tell you all about it
is that a record do you think no
probably not uh it's a personal it's a
personal record I don't think I've ever
been to more than two funerals or
Memorial services and some may call them
in one day
who called them them
well or you can call it a celebration of
life
like that's made its way into the into
the country yeah you know what the the
um funeral brochure
at at The Country Church that Christy
grew up in for the second funeral we
went to it said celebration of life I
was like I like this that's pretty nice
I like this
um did it feel like a celebration in
life
I would like to discuss that oh oh but
first I would like to acknowledge that
we're both flannel boys today yeah we're
in sync today we plan on boys with the
black T-shirt with the white ink what
are we doing I don't know but we're in
sync man this is gonna be a good podcast
we decided to not talk about it until
now and we also decided not to change
because it's like it does you know it's
different but the same if you're just
watching a clip from from your biscuits
this episode you'd be like oh they have
they decided to wear a uniform today
yeah plaid and black T-shirt but you
know it's just we're just we're tapping
into the same live stream of apparel
this is a synchronicity this is a
synchronicity
I will say what do we do with it I will
say briefly I I'm not going to talk
about this at length right now but I I'm
sure we will at some point
uh uh but people have pointed out
multiple you know whenever we talk about
things like when um when I did my
deconstruction episode and I was talking
about some of these things that were
happening and you know is this
challenging my worldview or inventing a
new one Whatever uh people point out the
fact that which is not unexpected that
all of these things have been talked
about
uh ad nauseam by many other people other
than me it's just I I tend to not be uh
very well educated about a lot of this
stuff right because
you know we've got a technical education
I've been making internet videos meaning
what I'm saying is that all the stuff
that we've been talking about there are
people who are uh educated and informed
and for you know centuries have been
talking about some of the things that we
talked about and I'm just sort of
riffing and just talking about my
personal experience
shame on you what but no but actually
it's no uh it it's I think it's good
this is It's good to hear people talk
about that because people point me to
people who've talked about it okay and
then it's very helpful for me to process
and so so they're not critiquing you uh
well some people are but it's not it's
not I'm saying some some people are
giving helpful suggestions some people
are critiquing I'm taking it all as
helpful suggestions
but one of the things I have really had
no idea about
um I mean I had a little bit of an idea
about you know
CG or Carl Jung which I always just said
Carl Jung
um and apparently uh he is the one that
made a lot of some of these Concepts
about like the collective unconscious
and synchronicity and all this stuff
because he was very much a guy that was
like one part of his brain was super
rational logical and the other part of
his brain was trying to figure out what
was going on Beyond and trying to
develop mystical way of thinking and
practice things together
and uh so I've been reading I'm not
having been reading him directly because
he's kind of hard to read directly but
I'm reading modern people's takes on him
who can explain it in a way that doesn't
make me fall asleep why did you say he
was CG I thought it was CJ
no CG what's the G I don't know Gustav I
think oh oh oh but young starts with a J
synchronicity right now well we're
probably just we probably just have
similar uh we have a crossover in our
wardrobes and it's inevitable that we're
going to wear similar things on some
days but we can choose to uh believe
that there's something else going on and
it's more fun I would like to harness it
yeah I like to harness harness it and
see if we can just work something up
today well since we're getting stuff off
our chest yeah I would say so thank you
thank you for those of you who suggested
different books and and resources
because I do appreciate it uh because I
admit and I'm not very well read in a
lot of these things I'm just kind of
experiencing life and then just going on
a podcast and talking about it so I did
not take offense at any of those
recommendations I welcome them speaking
to suggest a book I'd like to suggest a
book okay is this your wreck
um no this is an ad I would like to
suggest a book that has nothing in it
it's up to you to fill it and we sell it
mythical always creative it's you know
it's good to have a creative notebook
that has says nothing it's uh the doodle
book this actually features a doodle
from uh Caleb yep
our artists in Residence yeah and so the
only thing that's on the book is the
Mississippi and then you can put the
dragon on there your doodle anything you
want you don't have to do to what Caleb
doodled and then every day
or every moment
is a blank slate for you to Doodle
Express Yourself distract yourself I
recommend that that's my favorite book
right now
the mythical doodle book available at
mythical.com the book with nothing in it
this episode is brought to you by better
help I'm toying with a slogan and this
is not better help's slogan this is just
something that I'm toying with okay keep
surprising yourself hmm what about that
I like that how about that for like a
life motto if there's something fun
about surprising yourself with yourself
learning things about yourself like
little Easter eggs that you put around
in your life maybe you'll forget about
it and you'll be oh there's the five
dollars I put into that crack yeah it's
a rewarding experience which happens to
me in the context of therapy I mean I
surprised myself a lot did you learn new
things about yourself as I learn new
things about myself it's surprising it's
like oh connecting dots making
making connections between my actions my
fears my thoughts my my desires my past
my present my future yeah you're doing
the work there's all that doing the work
there's always something new you can
learn about yourself and therapy is a
great way to keep learning and
understand why you are the way you are
which I think is that that's for me what
I once would have uh regarded as like
you know self-obsessed Naval gazing I've
actually come to learn that figuring out
why I am the way that I am and how I got
to be this way and uh understanding that
is the first step to changing the things
about myself that I want to change if I
don't know how I got the way that I am I
can't take the next step to change uh
and adapt and as I've shared on this
podcast before learning to be much more
self-compassionate frees you up to then
love other people more if that's
something that you're interested in uh
you should give therapy a try and you
should give better help a try because of
how it works it's convenient because
it's entirely online so you can take
your appointments from anywhere you want
all you got to do is fill out a
questionnaire then you get matched up
with a licensed therapist that meets
your needs and if they're not a great
match you can change at no extra cost
discover your potential with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com ear today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
um I want to apologize for my tardiness
today
um
of course you were also tardy I think it
was tardier than you I was running late
because I
I had to flick my shower nipples
no comment and um once I got started
with that
I couldn't stop until I was done
please elaborate
I thought I've told you about my shower
nipples before
because you know I got I've got the
shower head beside me but then I've got
the Raindrop shower head overhead and
it's like he's got a bunch of nipples on
it it's got a bunch of nipples on it
like
um and then all the water
squirts out of the nipples like because
of the hardness of the water in our area
they get clogged yeah and the nipples
are um black rubber and then I can look
and I can see right at the tip of the
teat of each one there'll be like a
little white thing
if I reach up there and I just
pinch the nipple
the the frosty nip
will come off and the water will flow
again and the water will flow or not be
like
sideways I noticed that sometimes if if
I go long enough without flicking my
shower nipples
the
the the intensity of the the remaining
free-flowing nipples is such that it
feels like I'm being shot with like a
bunch of lasers yeah and then there's
one laser hitting the wall and one laser
hitting the shower door
you it's it's it's I feel like I need to
be dropped from the ceiling like Tom
Cruise well the intensity of to dodge it
the intensity of flow is proportional or
inversely proportional to the number of
nipples of course I know that and this
is why Chase who has a third nipple
which he's talked about has a very low
flow in his in his nipples because he
has you know he has a relief nipple is
what they call it well
it's the design is optimized for all of
the nipples to be free-flowing and you
tend to forget it's like all of a sudden
it's like man this hurts I don't even
want to turn this thing on but then I
went up there and I like system and
sometimes I'll just like I'll just rake
my hand over it I ain't got time for
this just like get all the nipples at
once it doesn't work that way you got to
sit there and you got to systematically
take your time go in It Go in a circle I
did it it took me so long my arm got
tired I had to switch arms all right and
you're just standing you're not like on
a stool I'm not on a stool no and then
and then I I got so tired I had to
switch arms back from what I remember in
filming that video in Your Shower
um which is on the internet I mean it's
this tall I had to reach pretty straight
it's a pretty tall shower
so I just systematically
pinched all of the shower nipples and
got all the little granules out this is
the only reason that you relate and then
well it took a long time and then I
turned I turned that shower head back on
and let me tell you
it was like it was like a brand new
morning
it was it was like a delicate
rain I was just underneath the delicate
rain I was like this is what this
thing's supposed to do yeah this is what
it was made for sometimes you just gotta
flick your nipples sometimes you got to
flick your shower nipples first thing in
the morning you know what
uh stop what you're doing Drop what
you're doing even you can keep listening
to this make your way to your shower
head at your next available entree and
start flicking those nipples now you're
assuming that everyone has a rain I mean
this is pretty privileged yeah sorry I
assume everybody if any of whatever your
shower head is you know you need to you
need to dunk that thing in some in some
vinegar water we definitely had no
nipples in my shower you gotta get you
gotta get that shower head
clean the shower head in my no matter
what it is vinegar was uh I don't know
if you remember this if you ever took a
shower at my house growing up I remember
the shower head
started like left the side of the wall
at my goozle height neck height and then
released at the top of chest height and
this is the shower that I grew up taking
showers in and probably at age he was
standing in a bathtub nine
I outgrew the shower but continued to
shower in the shower until 18. so you
would bend over to wash your hair yeah
or if you didn't want to wash your hair
was you didn't have to wear a shower cap
I didn't wear a shower cap until I got
this hair growing up I I'm gonna say
this is just growing up with just a mom
because the time that I grew up in the
hold on you're just really really really
messed up the synchronous messed up the
synchronous I got hot I had to take it
off well feel how thick my thing is hot
it's quilted mine's quilted
oh okay all right all right well I'm
just keeping mine on nice Jesus quilted
as yours is I'm getting mine on for now
I'll take mine off a little bit I
shouldn't put this on my mom but it was
her idea as a kid she was like
she would tell me things like you need
to wash your face every night with
Noxzema hmm she didn't have a daughter
you know well no that was important
forget gender Norms
I mean she taught me Skin Care at a
young age that's a lot of things a lot
of boys growing up around my time didn't
get taught I think you may be and then
but here's the other thing I think you
have a misconception about this just so
you understand well how about this
she said and you know what if you're if
your hair is good you can take a shower
with a shower cap
and as a kid
there were many times when I would
shower with a shower cap
well that's a very middle-aged woman
thing to do I think that's a little
unusual but what was the uh you ever
showered with a shower cap
I said yeah well now I do you have a
shower cap yeah people have my hair man
yeah man how embarrassing if I'm not
gonna watch it
I can't even sit here anymore I'm glad I
took my jacket off but here's the thing
I have what I have found
after having a shower cap for like the
first two years of this hair is that if
I just put my hair up same thing and
just kind of stand I don't have we don't
have a rain shower let it hit your
guzzle I just let it hit my face and a
little bit of hair gets wet but what
were those aren't you afraid oxy of
walking around with a shower cap
like aren't you afraid if you forget to
take it off you might come to work with
that thing no because in our bathroom we
have a mirror
oh yeah yeah so I usually see myself
after I get out of the show I had to
make a choice you know rain shower head
or a mirror Oxy pads do you remember
living with that choice it does yeah Oxy
pads so we had the wash that came with
that I remember you had all that and we
had Clearasil dude every teenager has a
should have like a face wash routine
because it was not zero I use Noxzema so
I'm just saying that I think that you
thought that you were the only boy that
was getting the the print print face
treatment but like
we were all burning our faces up trying
to keep the zits at Bay
you know yeah they have different
treatments now I've noticed
um tell me about North Carolina man
um it's wonderful you know it's a
wonderful State the pine tree the Pine
State
tell me about your specific experience
uh the state bird is the Cardinal
the state tree is the the main export
Longleaf pie was tobacco
uh for a month for a long time
um what is it now I bet it's um potatoes
no not potatoes but I've never seen a
potato well they're underground
we have to grow a lot of cotton now I
think anyway
well the the main thing that when when I
found out we were going back to North
Carolina I looked at the calendar just
to check and see if uh our school our I
can't say this word but I'm going to try
it alma mater good is that right good
hey
uh not good with me uh was hosting
yes hosting
the University of North Carolina Tar
Heels in basketball
um
this has been a pretty good year it's
not a great year for NC State basketball
and it is proving to be a pretty bad
year for UNC and I love it and the fact
that they have historically at least in
the sense you know
since the 80s have dominated us let's
just be clear about that in fact having
one uh 35 of the last 40 games that
we've played
ouch
um it's we just hate them with the with
a deep fiery passion
and I was like you know what I'd like to
go to that game because I don't go to NC
State sports games anymore because I
don't live there and it's it's on the
weekend you know what I'll do I'll reach
out to the person that we know at the
engineering school
uh Dr Jerome Lavelle
uh who we we know from the time we took
a tour of NC State's engineering school
a few years ago yeah and uh when we were
on the Bleak Creek uh tour yeah
and so we reached out and I was like Hey
because I mean I looked and all the
tickets the whole thing was sold out
already so yeah and he was like yeah you
know what actually it works out the the
dean's uh personal two of his personal
tickets he's not using or whatever so I
was like oh great I'll take my dad to
basketball game great father-son bonding
nice pack play and he was like I'd love
for you to
um stop by the engineering school
on the Friday before uh-huh you're gonna
be there for you know Friday through
Monday these tickets aren't completely
free and uh you know show you around
show you around a little bit maybe have
you meet some students I was like sure
I'd love to do that that's cool because
last time that we were there we did go
over to the uh Centennial Campus where
the engineering school is but we didn't
really go into many things either it was
just the time of year I I don't remember
exactly what was going on but I got a
way better tour than we got just so you
understand I'm gonna tell you about some
things that I saw yeah it was it was uh
classes weren't in session or something
okay it was a strange time
it was cool to go back but yeah we
didn't get to see that much
well
as you know most of the engineering
buildings are on the Centennial Campus
the Newark campus yeah you have to kind
of I mean it's a little bit of a drive
to get to
and um
he was like I'm going to take you into
some of the labs
where some students are doing some
interesting work okay
and
I mean I don't think I have to tell you
how much
NCC has changed since we went there you
know it's been a short 20 something
years since we graduated
Centennial Campus was just getting
started when we were there it was very
ambitious like the buildings were huge
but there wasn't anybody there yeah it
was like hardly anything was happening
we didn't I I took no classes there oh
yeah it was right after us that they
started populating more stuff over there
at that remote campus and this is
there's been a a huge change in just the
philosophy of architecture and building
spaces for
universities and in corporations the the
the very open Airy natural light all
that stuff is kind of a new thing that's
happened over the past 20 years and it's
just infiltrated Corporate America but
also American universities and any new
buildings they're building right so
because if you think of course they
still only use brick at state right on
the outside yeah
but
like we walked past man Hall which is
the the building that I took a lot of my
civil engineering classes in it was the
civil engineering building and it's
currently being completely like redone
but you know I don't remember what
building you did most of your classes in
but I'm sure it was a very similar
approach Park shops
okay I think is what it was called but
like when you went into the front door
of man Hall there was a lobby area that
was
a Lobby like the size of a like a
mansion or like like a foyer in a large
home you know what I'm saying it was
yeah not a big space and it was one
story and there were barely any windows
in there and there was like a little
seating area
but now when you walk into so there's uh
this interestingly the civil engineering
and the industrial engineering uh
departments are in the same building
synchronicity there you go there's like
a you know
it was like it's like the Rhett and Link
building
he didn't ask me to make it the red link
building did but he was planning to see
I mean I mean I mean I don't know I mean
they're not going to turn away donation
and come out and ask how much does it
cost to name a building way more than
we're willing to pay yeah I didn't even
ask that question like I didn't even ask
so
um
but I was just blown away as we walked
into these buildings with just the
lobbies I mean I'm just I was getting
fixated on just the lobby I didn't know
you were a Lobby man I'm I am now I
didn't know I was a Lobby guy but I'm a
Lobby guy when you've got a Lobby that's
three stories high and this all this
open seating and all this natural light
and I it's just it gives you a feeling I
want to learn do they have hammocks no
because to me that's the wrong message
that's the final frontier because every
College Lobby is just it's all about
where am I going to take a nap next that
was fun for you and I don't think that's
a widespread practice because more
people or most people have shame concept
called Shame and we are well aware of
that I definitely have shame but it
ain't got nothing to do with the shame
leaves the building when I'm sleeping
that's the great thing about me and
Shane well here's naps but they need
hammocks in more campus places well
there's these cool things called dorm
rooms and there's these better things
called don't patronize meats that are in
those
but
then he took me to the actual lab areas
where students are doing these
experiments and just I gotta just I
don't know what kind of you know
sort of like robots and stuff you had
access to the industrial engineering
school I don't think any no none
it's crazy what are you talking about
you saw robots oh yeah I don't mean like
may I help you kind of robots
I mean
there's this giant may I help you
navigate that Lobby there's this giant I
mean I'm sure they'll have that soon but
there's this giant multi-story open area
with all these stations and of course
you've got your 3D printers and I don't
mean like your little I mean 3D printers
the size of this table around and then
robotic arms doing things and just all
throughout this facility all this stuff
that we just didn't have access to and
maybe if we had access to it we'd still
be Engineers so I mean you know Catch 22
there
um but he was like I want to take you to
some Labs where students are doing some
interesting work
and it was pretty cool because
um at least for the most part it seemed
like these students these graduate
students whether they be you know just a
graduate student or a PhD student have
been prepared you know we're bringing by
uh an alumnus
and uh he's an internet comedian he
doesn't do any engineering anymore but
he wanted to go to the state Carolina
game tonight
[Laughter]
um
they had been prepped they had a little
something to say oh you know welcome to
Moe's it was almost like that
but I went into one lab and there was
this long
chamber that like a water chamber that
was they were doing some work on it but
it's basically like to generate a wave
to like a study erosion and that kind of
thing okay but then there was all these
pipes in there and there was this woman
in there in a white coat and a you know
safety goggles
and she explained that what she is
working on is she is working with
fungi
that are designed to break down certain
waste products in Wastewater systems
whether that be Plastics or whatever and
there's also some that you know those
those fat burgs you know the oil
deposits the grease deposits that get
into City stores yes oh God don't show
me a picture like internet videos well
they're developing
you know fungi that are going to that
can attack this stuff and and take care
of it and of course the first thing that
I'm thinking the last of them might have
you watched the last of us I mean that's
all I can do you ask her that being out
of this field for so long and never
really having been in that particular
field of getting that technical I'm an
Entertainer can we talk about a show
yeah and uh I I said and so that was
kind of my ended up kind of being my
go-to thing as you'll you'll see as I
talk about the other place that I went
was this idea that this woman is working
with
mushrooms she's working with a fungus
that you know it felt like it could turn
on her and that was I just said I just
said be careful that was basically my
advice was I just listen I'm only four
episodes in but I just gotta say be
careful I really believe in what you're
doing can I ask a potentially dumb
question because yeah uh you can more
than one what what you can ask more than
one
well I never have
this is my one
maybe it's in a dumb question but like I
don't know I'm seeing it from a
different angle like you've been talking
about fungus and then I'm like yeah
mushrooms and then I realized that like
when you get a fungal infection
when you get a fungal infection is that
a is that mushrooms oh no mushrooms is
is a type of fungus oh good but there's
yeast is a fungus oh that's right
that's right yeah so no it doesn't
necessarily mean so they want so she
wasn't working with mushrooms but I say
uh no but
in The Last of Us it is a mushroom I
know that yeah so
I mean maybe if I just yeast I could
eventually become a mushroom if you let
it go
yeah it just becomes bread
is bread a mushroom I mean this is a
good point to say they've they've
invited me to give the commencement
address at the industrial engineering
school and listen to me talk right now
well and what on Earth and you know that
uh and is this is this been confirmed
that I am giving the commencement
address at the civil engineering
department
okay yeah so yeah thanks to me well okay
let's get this straight I feel like the
industrial engineering department is a
fan of mine in 2019
they gave me an award or maybe 2018.
or maybe 20 I don't know when it was we
were both asked to give the respective
commencement addresses we will turn it
down at the time because of schedule
and then when it resurfaced the
conversation was about you giving the
comment address yeah industrial
engineering and so they thought better
about you and then when you decided that
you were going to do it I was like well
I should probably offer my services to
the civil engineering department and so
that is what is happening
no that that was what was going to
happen and then it was covered and we it
didn't happen at all yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then
there was an invitation again yeah yeah
um and it was to me
well it was maybe it was the most recent
time
I like my version of the story is your
version of the story always puts you in
the center we know link because I was
asked to give the commencement
speech again and then uh you were like
I'll offer my services again well
because I if you're gonna go if you're
gonna take like your trip if you're
gonna go take a weekend away right I
mean if I go back to North Carolina
and here's the thing hi having uh taken
a tour of the engineering school and
interacted with some of the students
which I'm about to tell you about I feel
like I'm probably better prepped than
you at this point well that was my point
exactly I'm not prepped in any way well
I after I have no business doing this
I'm honored but I have well as I will
make a little bit I don't have any
business doing it either but I don't
think that's why they're talking to us
yeah I after talking to the fungus lady
uh went into a materials lab
and
there were three guys in there
and they were they were ready man they
had a little they were ready
Welcome to our lab yo it wasn't quite
that engaging uh but he did say we are
working on
self healing
carbon
materials carbon fiber and some other
material I was like
and that was the moment I said I feel
like every time every conversation I
start in this place feels like the
beginning of a dystopian yeah Thriller
you know yeah so I ended up just you
know just go sideways ended up telling
them to be careful too oh yeah so I am
so my message I'm just letting you know
I'm giving you a little preview of my
commitment commencement is be careful be
careful y'all yeah yeah you don't know
the power that you wield yeah you're
gonna be the reason that this all
self-healing how does that work so
essentially like let's say you had a
wing that was made out of carbon fiber
you know which is a great idea right
we've got a very light
strong material
well
they actually talked about a a heat
activated adhesive and I said like a
chip bag
right we've done that on good mythical
morning we resealed a chip bag with a
with a flat iron you know that was what
I had to offer just so you understand
yeah you made yourself we're still doing
engineering yeah that's what I learned
right
and so they basically have layers
they're like no not exactly they have
layers of heat activated adhesives that
are inside the carbon fiber structure
and then they have very small wires that
go through that so that they can conduct
an electrical current through it that
will activate it and when there's a
break or something it automatically
activates the current once these no I
don't know exactly I mean I'm sure that
might be what they do at some point but
I think you can turn like hit the
self-healing button again we're in the
early stages of this link we at the NC
State Engineering School okay you know
I'm a part of that I've been to on a
tour yep
um but anyway it was super cool I did
once he started talking about how it
works and how it lays itself back down
and that was when I began I was like
yeah self-healing you had me at
self-healing you had me in a Lobby
really
and uh I can't I talked to somebody else
he was doing something else uh but I
they can they make it cry uh it's not
it's not a it doesn't have a soul yet
okay like I feel like when it gets hurt
it should cry and that should be the
that should be
the external notifications hey I'm
self-healing right now you can put that
in your commencement speech
but then I want to fly in a plane that
cries Dr Lavelle was like I've gathered
some students engineering Scholars I
think he said oh he was like they're
basically like engineering students who
are leading in different areas I've
gathered them in a smarty pants they're
in there with some pizza and some soda
oh hell yeah and I would like you to
have a word with them oh yeah I I would
like you to give them some remarks here
we go you know and he was like like do
you need any time do you need any time
he's like no man oh God you're standing
I was like you you you're about to ask
me to do what I do best
impromptu speaking we just start talking
to people in a crowd do you need any
time I would I'd have probably been like
yeah and then I would have bolted and I
love the fact though because if we sit
down in there and he's like uh
the way he framed it was
uh Rhett has some things he wants to
share with you
and I was like oh do I
know red has some do you need some time
because I'm about to tell him you got
some things yeah let's let's see if I do
have some things to share yeah what did
you do with that
uh well I kind of went off of the fact
that I had just experienced these things
these very cool things and I used that
to talk about first of all the fact that
I felt like every conversation that I
was having was the beginning of a
dystopian novel and that they should be
careful so I kind of took my be careful
theme and I gave it to them can I ask
you another question is this a dumb one
this is a smart one okay
how
how many students were there 26 20. so
that's a tough
size that's a tough size how loud
was your speaking voice like what tone
did you use demonstrate that did you
talk to them like you're talking to me
right now no it was or did you talk to
them it was more like thanks for having
me
because it was in the lobby and it's a
very it's a very you were on the other
side of the large lobby but you kind of
have to make a like do you did you go
into speech mode or were you very much
in like
no I was leaning back
yeah you were seated yeah you know my
voice projects pretty well but you were
seated yeah okay all right yeah I didn't
stand up okay good I'm not I don't do
that yeah I'm already you know I'm
Already There height when I'm sitting
down
um you're their standing height but then
I said uh and again this wasn't planned
this just go this was just kind of just
happened I thought this was a good one I
thought this is a good way for the thing
to develop I said I was in town to see
us beat Carolina tomorrow yeah and and
and and Dr Lavelle wanted to give me a
little tour of things and show me the
latest and greatest in the engineering
school
and and going around and talking with
these individuals working on these
different things I just want to let you
know that you're doing really important
work unlike the students at Carolina
so so that was kind of what I did my bit
was the students at Carolina think that
they're doing important things you know
in the humanities yeah yeah yeah but
what they're doing doesn't have an
impact on the world well you you guys
are solving real problems you are
helping the state the nation and the
world in significant ways were they
laughing at least yeah yeah I got some
laughs I got you know 20 is it 20 you
know you know 20. it's yeah they're not
going to roll on the floor or anything
and um there's not going to be any
clapping yeah I mean I did leave out the
fact that like there you know UNC has a
good medical school I kind of set aside
the medical Sciences for a second it was
just kind of talking about like
journalism school you know pay no
attention to the medical Sciences yeah
happening over here
um did you mention I don't know me uh it
probably you probably came up
exactly
okay
um no I'm sure I talked about you and I
said uh that you were an Industrial
Engineer and that I was a civil engineer
okay
um I ended up saying that
um
you know I talked about I told my story
of almost changing from Communications
to from engineering to Communications
once I decided I probably wasn't going
to be an engineer forever
um but then my dad was like you can do
everything that you everything that you
can do with a communications degree you
can do with an engineering degree but
not the other way around
and that logic made sense to me so I
stayed and it ended up working out huh
and I kind of just making the point of
like listen I'm not doing important
things you guys are trying probably not
true by the way you guys I just want to
go ahead and say that's probably not
true
I think it probably is I don't know the
most part I think it's generally not I'm
sure there's there's going to be
examples hashtag year biscuits
things that a Communications major can
do that an engineering major can't uh
yeah
there might be exceptions but in a
general rule most of the jobs you can
get in Communications don't require so
you told them special training what was
the you were telling them switch no well
there was a girl who would change who
they went around and said where they
were from and what they had changed what
they were majoring in in one of them was
like I I just switched to marketing but
I'm still in this thing so you belittled
her and so I kind of I singled her out I
was like Melissa I know you just changed
the marketing uh I know you just made a
huge and listen life-altering mistake
some people got to do that some people
got to tell the story of what's going on
here there's some awesome stuff
happening
I spun it pretty nicely but what my
point was is that what we do I said you
guys are doing important work you're
you're getting the Fat Burgers out of
pipes you know I'm determining what's
the best flavor of Pop-Tart which is not
even really helpful because it's just
what I think and what you think yeah um
even though I was making light of what
we do I understand what why what we do
is important but it's not really
important for the utility of what we're
doing is more important for the the vibe
that it's creating or whatever you know
um but it made me think I was like they
are actually doing really important
stuff like I'm not saying that I had
never thought about this
but I was yeah I was like we have all
these problems that we are facing as a
society
um and a lot of these problems are being
made worse by things like
climate change you know because there's
one they're they're thinking there's
there's Coastal Engineering as a whole
department
they're thinking about the coast they're
thinking about erosion they're thinking
about
the forests along the coast and
vegetation and all this stuff those
environments
um they're just doing really really
important things
thing that you know have an immediate
impact as soon as you graduate and start
working in these fields it kind of makes
me nervous about my commencement address
now
I mean it's like it's like it would
matter
was this a dry run for you you think
you're going to go back to the state
Carolina bit
I I considered it I considered I might
use a little bit of that I might it
might be a little riff yeah in there
about how well they do matters
unlike
Carolina
I I I'm starting to percolate some ideas
for my speech
and I think it's um right now I'm just
really I think I'm going to go weird
well I fully expected that yeah yeah I
think I'm gonna I'm gonna teach him a
lesson you're going to confuse a lot of
parents yeah yeah I'm gonna confuse the
parents yeah I'm going to teach them a
lesson for asking me to do this and
never and ruin all our chances of ever
giving like the school-wide commencement
right right we're just on the college
College of Engineering levels I kind of
see that I can't get to the big level I
kind of see that as my role in this
tandem operation is that my role is to
secure us a spot at giving the
school-wide commencement at some point
for NC State yeah and and to make them
have that awkward conversation it's like
can you not bring him
because of what he did yeah yeah you
know that well maybe you got the tall
ones I got some more time to figure it
out but honestly I've I think about it
way too much like I there's a little bit
of nervousness there but like I'm trying
to psych myself up to just not even
think about it like I might end up going
I wouldn't totally totally
you know unprepared don't don't give too
much away because this comes out before
you give the commencement speeches so
yeah well I got I don't have anything to
give away
and reconsider you don't want them to
reconsider you know what links oh you
don't want them to receive you think
they're going to rescind I don't know
about this a couple things y'all have
said are not helping your cases Link's
gonna do a great job
that's the one who asked for it I'm the
one who was invited to do it I'll just
make sure no one at NC State listens to
this episode oh man I mean when we did
go back it's reminded me of the time
that we did go back and it was it was
fun
because we went we went before a crowd
of
students
and we did like a panel and I I just
really I really had a blast just cutting
up
you know yeah everybody goes in that
environment they take themselves a
little too seriously
you know we gotta we gotta shape the
future generation yeah no I'm just going
to give him a little comic relief I'm
gonna give him a little confusion
take them off their balance
just so you know I do think that the
expectations are pretty low yeah you
know for the individual it's just not
even the engineering school this is the
individual Department graduation I don't
know how many students are going to be
there
you know what are we talking
80.
120.
I don't know they're trying there's
there's like 10 000 students in
undergrad engineering total are you yeah
let me talk to you about my yeah yeah my
trip do that um because I went to a
couple of funerals yeah yeah we say The
Best For Last
um I was reminded of something at one of
these funerals
uh uh the the the speaker the preacher
um
you know seemed like a great guy I'm not
critiquing the guy but he reminded me of
a principal
and that is
um at a funeral when you're you're
you're talking about this person and
you're like referencing their faiths
there's like there's this thing which he
referred to as
preaching somebody into heaven
um and of course you're talking about
the dead person yeah preaching the dead
person in heaven now this is not a
belief that somebody can
um
get into heaven after I said I I think
that's a Mormon belief but it's not a
um a country Church Christian belief no
right
that after somebody dies well their
their their fate is sealed that is the
belief their faith once you die and you
go to the other side and you you're
there for eternity Heaven or Hell
and um so you got to make your decision
on this side of that for yourself now
can't nobody preach you into heaven but
and the reason why it came up was he was
talking about uh
the deceased as someone that he he knew
his he knew his faith
and he like it's like I can certify I
don't need to preach him into heaven now
I Don't Preach people in heaven to
clarify you say you said what it wasn't
but to say what it is said say what it
is it's when you it's when a preacher is
preaching a funeral and the deceased
they they have their doubts about the
deceased person's face and if it has
qualified them to be in heaven now and
of course you want to provide Comfort to
the family and within that belief system
you want to be able to say well they
checked the boxes of
faith in Jesus Christ
in this particular way that we all agree
is the way that you get into heaven so
um if you you want to give the people
comfort that this person's in heaven
you'll see him again but if there's
doubts about it you kind of gotta spin
it in a hopeful positive way that this
speaker preacher described as preaching
them into heaven I knew exactly what he
was talking preaching about them as if
they are in heaven now yeah even though
he or she the preacher has their doubts
right you know and he said I don't do
that I Don't Preach people in heaven
okay he doesn't do that he doesn't do
that in this common practice but he's
also but he was making the point in this
case
I don't need to do that because I know
that he's there I knew his faith well
enough to know that he's there and you
got nothing to worry about you can be
comforted does that mean that there are
times when this preacher
think somebody might be in hell that he
says that I don't yeah I don't I don't
know what he just refused to do the
funeral maybe he refuses I think so he's
like I can't preach him into heaven so
I'm bowing out of this one
hmm so that was that was like one of the
points he was making to give Comfort to
them but like for me and then I was kind
of you know I'm in this interesting
place right so it's like my vantage
point is
I was not only thinking about me but
other people in the crowd who were like
well uh uh I don't know if I'm if
if you so you would you certainly
wouldn't certify that I'm I'm going to
heaven oh gosh I just I just spilled my
drink
um it just made me feel it made me feel
a little weird
you know it's like
um I understand
that you want to give people comfort
that in especially
if if they believe
in heaven
you know that people are going there
that that their loved one is now there
that they moved on to a better place
um but I don't know it just and and
uh
I don't know it just made me feel funny
man well did he turn it on to to the
crowd
because my experience yeah Evangelical
funerals is that they don't make it
about the deceased person they make it
about you making the decision on this
side of
death and I will say to seal your faith
that there are many people who who die
who want their funeral to be
to bring people to a point of decision
about Jesus right so I don't think it's
necessarily disrespectful to the
deceased person but I have been to
funerals in which
I knew that the deceased person did not
want their funeral to be turned into an
invitation for people to make a decision
for Jesus and to examine their own lives
but that was the preacher's prerogative
and so that's what he did yeah that's
what that's what feels a little weird
too and it kind of brought that up you
know it's like because this the other
funeral was the one that said
celebration of life and it was much more
just about
bringing Comfort to the family through
like there were scripture readings
and like a a little sermon
that it was very much just about
Comfort it wasn't about okay this is
this is where the deceased person is and
that's why you need comfort it's just
you know
God's here for you and you know it was
it was
it was more generally comforting it
wasn't about like
um asserting someone's
eternity
um and it was also you know people spoke
and it was it was a celebration of life
and you know what even with the even
with the first one the one where with
the preaching preaching somebody in
heaven happened
the front that was talked about
the best part was that an a handful of
people got up and spoke about the
deceased I love that that is great
that's my favorite thing about a funeral
is celebrating like people sharing from
their heart about how they've been
touched people who don't like to speak
publicly and have like by their own
admission say I have no business being
up here I hate this but I love this
person so much that I want to be up
there and saying something like I love
that I'll keep going to funerals because
for that to happen you know but this but
this whole like
you know you got to feel like all right
this is my CH this is my chance we got
we got everybody here
thinking about death now's when we're
gonna get them now's when we're gonna
get them we're now we're gonna get him
into heaven yeah you know
I just felt
yeah I just don't I don't I don't love
that I don't love that I don't want that
at my funeral oh well because well I
gotta change a lot of my plans now
because I was first of all I was
planning on doing your eulogy and I was
planning on making it a really really
intense
intense moment
intense moment where everyone was gonna
have to like you can go around pointing
at everybody and they got to say where
they're they're
Eternal functions well I was once at a
funeral uh where someone's speaking
about the deceased uh paused
for an uncomfortably long time okay
probably a minute
and just didn't say anything 60 seconds
is a long time to not talk it well the
reason I say a minute without a heads up
it felt like two and so I'm gonna say
that it was probably one
and
it was one of those things where the
question in my mind was
is this person
getting choked up because it didn't seem
like they were about to get choked up
but sometimes you can get choked up you
know when I get choked up I have a I
have trouble just getting any words out
and so I was like okay maybe that's
what's happening but I don't see any
evidence of that
and then he said that was awkward wasn't
it
that was uncomfortable actually with the
words that was uncomfortable wasn't it
oh no
well one minute of discomfort in this
service
compare that to an eternity in hell
oh my God
this was at a funeral dance
and making the point and because the
woman was a Christian the woman was an
Evangelical Christian and this is what
she would have wanted
I mean maybe not exactly that
but again it's just like I I just
remember
every funeral I remember the way we
would talk about it was
that's a threat preacher did a good job
preacher did a good job and and it's a
threat the gospel went out and that that
was the standard the gold sander for a
funeral was if the gospel was presented
clearly
and there are many positive ways to
present the gospel to present the good
news that you can have
a relationship with God through Jesus
for eternity if that's your thing
there's plenty of positive ways to do
that I mean and a lot of that happened
in the service and it was mostly through
the people sharing about this person's
life and celebrating it and the fact
that their faith was a part of that was
very Winsome you know it's like no
threats needed you know it's like people
get so damn heavy-handed because they
feel like they've got they got to you
know it's like well it's it's life or
death you know you gotta you gotta act
this way but it's just not effective and
it feels kind of
it feels kind of icky well I think
that's the interest I mean that one that
one especially the interesting part of
this is if I was being not that I am and
I would not accept accept this uh except
this offer if I was uh being serving as
a consultant to an Evangelical
Church
who was looking to make an impact on
people
I would be like yeah yeah yeah this this
push energy you know I heard somebody
recently yeah yeah the push versus the
pull and so if you're trying to persuade
someone or something
pushing them towards that thing is
almost always going to be met with
resistance right but if you create a
situation and that they will be pulled
and attracted towards whatever it is
that you're trying to persuade them of
first of all it gives them the power of
choice and decision and makes them and
it's much more likely that whatever
decision they make will be long lasting
exactly if I push on the shower nipple
what's going to happen
the water is going to go shoot off to
the side as far away from me as quickly
as possible but if I pull on the shower
nipple
and I release
I don't know how that fits into the
analogy if I release the Little Rock
where you're going and boom instead of
I'm getting I'm getting I'm getting I'm
getting just getting sprayed all over
the face with it and this can be a very
difficult coming to me this is a
difficult principle to follow I mean
especially for somebody like me I you
know I tend to get into a place where I
just want to just
persuade someone of something you know
and it not only tell them like it is and
first of all I want to I am and have
been for quite some time letting go of
that first of all once you become more
and more unsure about these things you
become much less
interested in persuading people of
anything right yeah
um in fact I'm much more persu I'm much
more persuaded to persuade people to be
less sure about the things that they
think about the you know that's kind of
where I'm at right now but even then I
just don't want to be
forcing an idea on somebody or
critiquing there and I'm not saying I I
do I do end up doing this I fall into
the Trap of critiquing and pushing and
but I think if you can just be like hey
can we create an environment and I mean
this is free advice for churches
everywhere
create an environment that people are
attracted to you know yeah and many many
do that I mean this is not
the things that we're talking about are
not a blanket statement that is just
like
I don't know if I don't know if funerals
are fraught with this but I mean we run
into it enough over the years to know
that it's something that happens but
it's not I'm not I'm not giving a
church-wide critique or like a
denomination-wide group no no it's like
but but it is common I've seen it enough
and it was more common in the past and
you know I was asking Lando about it
afterward I was like what did you think
about
um the funeral and he told me some stuff
and I was like what did you think about
like the sermon part and he was like you
mean the part where that guy was yelling
at us
and he actually you know I didn't I
wouldn't have characterized it as
yelling but he but oh it's like oh
through his through his lens that's how
he was like yeah that's exactly how he
there's an intensity too there's an
intensity to things that you say from
the pulpit that if you don't come from
that tradition right
you're like in in any other walk in any
other scenario in life if someone was
speaking in this way they would be upset
with me yeah yeah
right yeah but we just kind of like oh
that's just a preacher yelling he's
that's a preacher preaching yeah and
there's also another thing that happens
that preachers do that I've observed
quite a bit which is when they want to
get kind of fake emotional about
something and they're making a point
about something and you're like dude
you're not actually upset about this
this is the third service of the Sunday
you're doing the same thing that this is
a prepared thing that you've come up
with that you're trying to make this
point and I just wish I just wish that
you would understand this thing and I'm
really passionate about but you're not
passionate about it right now I mean
that's more of a pull so not all pulls
work ah no well if pushing is yelling
and pulling his car I feel like that's
still pushing yeah I feel like that's
manipulative yeah and and the funny
thing is is like okay Lando perfect
example of this as a young as a young
person
empathetic guy too
but in general
the younger generation
they see through
every thing they see through everything
they they know the moment that you are
uh trying to reject something that isn't
authentic and it's just and again I'm
not obviously there's plenty of
religious leaders who have figured this
out and are now using these principles
to manipulate people the appearance of
authenticity and vulnerability
but so you know and but I'm I think that
you know
the this generation what generation is
Lando what do you call that
I don't know he's he's about
he's 13.
Alpha yeah
start over
he's generating generation Alpha more
than anybody man
you see through everything
so born in 2010
that's still generation Alpha
he's not Z
I just didn't know if he was beta
year is 2010 so he's on the customer
2010 is the first year of alpha there
you go so all our kids are alpha
no
um Linda was my youngest
yeah but at the first oh the it
started in 2010. so he's the only one
that's out and all the rest of our kids
are Z
yeah huh because 24 2004 2008.
wow well 2009 2000 2010 starts Alpha
anyway
um uh all in all the the the the funeral
experiences were nice especially because
the second one
um the deceased the loved fish stew and
and everybody stayed was invited to stay
I thought the way you said was like
especially because the deceased
it came back from the deadline man I'm
sorry it just now he didn't seemed like
no disease set up and says it's on Tick
Tock now fish tooth and everybody got
fish stew everybody ate fish stew which
is like a Downy staple that Christy
makes has she made it for you
I don't know if I've had our fish too is
it a tomato based tomato so it's kind of
like Brunswick stew but with fish is
that how you would you describe it yeah
it they're not it doesn't have to be
tomato based they had a they had a a
clear base and a tomato base
and then it's potatoes they had two
options yep
big pots of this and they had flounder
in it but you can also like put canned
salmon in it well that's an example of
uh pull energy is when you serve fish
too everybody wants to stay
um so there's fish potatoes shrimp
and the really good ones you throw in
some shrimp
um onions
that's pretty much it but it's it's it
was an acquired taste for me but now I
really love it and you like cut up
cheese and like you make your bowl and
you put cheese in the side and then that
like big hunk of cheese will melt of
course cheese yeah yeah not supposed to
do that according to Leviticus and then
some white bread
they had they had every table had a loaf
of white bread on it oh so I can
critique
I you know uh
Hometown Faith but I can't do it too
much because they got they got a lot of
stuff right too every table's got a loaf
of white bread on it
it's like that's good that erases a
world of preaching people into heaven in
my mind I keep coming back the food is
so good I keep coming back for more baby
so
um that was it I made it through the
funerals we supported the families and
I'm glad we were there it was the right
thing to do I've rescheduled my trip to
Cabo don't you worry okay so I'm still
not invited nope
um I'll um
I'll close by telling you a little bit
about uh you sound like a preacher right
now I'm on Columbia clothes I understand
you about one of my experiences
uh the basketball game
so I know you've made it clear that you
don't care about sports but a lot of
people do and uh I also have cared
but you know
I respect as as I have aged
I have been able to
detach myself a little bit from or to
recognize how ridiculous when you really
think about it how ridiculous it is
to care
about
these students who go to this school
that you went to 20 years ago
in their ability to get a ball through a
basket better than the students from
another school that your wife went to
like I understand that if you really
break this down and look at it it does
not make sense it's not rational
you should not have emotional
attachments to these outcomes it's a
farce that being said I also understand
that on a deep psychological level that
I would probably be able to articulate
well if I had read more
and taking more than psych 101
it is connecting with something deep
within us that is just a part of our DNA
right
and uh the and we don't have those
Outlets like we are we live in a modern
society like I don't have to defend my
Village against the other Village like I
just don't have to do that yet I mean
maybe that'll happen as the world
continues to fall apart but right now
I just kind of just I say hey to the
garbage man you know what I'm saying
like I did say hey to my neighbor I
don't worry about my life as I'm
traversing to work I'm also not like
looking at an opportunity to like get a
deer to bring home to my family we live
in the modern times right we do we do
but because we've got all these systems
in us that are geared towards defending
the village we put that into sports
and even though you can step back and
observe it and understand how ridiculous
it is I find myself getting so caught up
in it
and of course I hate Carolina
for reasons that I cannot even
articulate
mostly because they have beaten our
brains in for years
and
I was like okay there's an opportunity
here we're good this year they're not
good
for some reason that usually doesn't
matter and they always end up like
playing really well against us and
beating us anyway yeah
so I kind of went into this with the
game with these low expectations
and then it's like the game starts and
we're not playing well shooting horribly
our best player is not really scoring
they start kind of building a lead in
the second half and I just had this
narrative that I began to play out in my
mind which is I was excited about this I
knew I shouldn't have been excited about
it I knew they were going to beat us
again for the you know 36th time in the
past 41 tries or whatever it was
and then
we just kind of we turn things around
and there was an incredible little run
which scored like seven or nine points
really really quickly oh wow they
weren't scoring baskets and they started
scoring more baskets yes and it sounds
really Dynamic the energy in that place
was crazy like and it was you know I
just haven't been I've been to like a
Clippers game and you've been to a
Clippers game with me but you know NBA
is different in in sports in Los Angeles
are different because everybody you know
40 of the the audience is rooting for
the other team because they're from
somewhere else and they prefer their
Hometown team more than they do the
local team
especially if the Clippers
and so I haven't been in this
everyone is really into the outcome of
this game and everyone is really
committed to it and to see it turn
around
it was and I've got I've got the video
on my on my phone if like when we had
gone up by 12 with a minute left and
there was moments when you know my dad
is pretty impartial he's got one son
that went to Carolina one son that went
to
uh State he's got a nephew I mean he's
got a grandson at Carolina right now
that he he goes and sees quite a bit so
my dad wore green Argyle to the uh to
the game which is did he get caught up
in it though which is I mean once we
started coming back he's he's standing
up like where you you you can't help
yourself he's got to be with you on this
one I mean shot we're standing up and
just like giving high fives and just it
was I mean it was electric and I was
like oh man I love this I love it now if
they had gone the other way it would
have like ruined my day yeah and but
there's something about giving yourself
over to this outcome
could be awesome or or ruined
hey that's steaks and I'm choosing to
I'm like I want to have that kind of
experience you know when I can I'm not
gonna like go back and watch a bunch of
games but
uh boy when we win like that and we beat
them we beat them yeah I know when
they're down they're not great they've
lost like the past four out of five
games or something but I don't care we
beat Carolina it feels it felt so good I
loved it
highly recommend highly recommend
watching your uh your college beat their
rival that's your recommended it's my
recommendation this week uh no that's
just a general recommendation don't well
listen it's my recommendation
and I I gotta I got a good one if you if
you're not into sports this is for youth
if you are into sports this is for you
if you're in an instrumental music this
is for you and if you're not this is
still for you even though it is
instrumental
check out oh my God I I think this is
gonna stay as one of my favorite albums
of all time because it so fits a certain
mood like it is a sweet spot this Niche
that this album occupies that I didn't
have an album in this place
you know a completely instrumental
vibey
listen to it use it for what you want
but I think that it's gonna it's gonna
feel a little niche I know it will for
me for the rest of my life
Mac DeMarco
Mac I love you man uh this is an
invitation to come on Good Mythical
Morning I'd love to I'd love to have you
come through it I'm very inspired by
your album five easy hot dogs five easy
hot dogs
uh
uh he he took a road trip I believe it
was up the uh Northern California coast
yeah you went all the way well he went
all the way up from
Crescent City up to Portland like you
went all the way up to Vancouver
Edmonton he went all the way up there
well then he went to Chicago
that's not I took a road trip he took a
road trip Chicago is not uh in Northern
California and neither is most of the
places that I mentioned but he made this
music as he traveled it's all
instrumental it's very um I played it
for you isn't it awesome hard vouch for
this yes hard vouch uh five easy hot
dogs just give it a listen it'll get it
it's a vibe Mac DeMarco five easy hot
dogs you're welcome
thanks for joining us for another year
biscuit join the conversation on the
internet hashtag earbiscus also you can
call us we have a number you can leave a
voicemail with thoughts questions
critiques book suggestions
1888 earpod one love you
hey just listening to the ear biscuits
episode that came out today something
that gives me a taste Chasm is the Nerds
Rope clusters I'm so addicted to them I
go through literally a bag in two days
so I've had to stop myself from buying
them because they're probably so bad for
me if you guys haven't had them yet you
should definitely try them thanks love
the podcast bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]